aleksander and Jim I remember talking
with you about this movie about 10 years
ago I think that was maybe when you had
the first idea or conversation do I have
the timing about right yeah I don't
remember the conversation exactly of the
time he had wanted this to be our first
film after sideways and it wasn't but
tell me about the evolution about what
that time meant and what the process of
writing demanded in terms of time yeah
we had no idea that this would take so
darn long to get made and it took so
long really for two reasons one the
screenplay was hard too because it's
such a big idea and you can take it in
so many directions we had the premise
it's a good movie premise it's silly and
serious and cinematic and allows for a
lot of you know allows us to throw our
net of let's say social satire around a
lot of things how do you find the right
story and character to serve as a
vehicle to guide us through a world in
which downsizing could actually happen
so that took longer than we thought and
then it was nearly impossible to find
funding we first tried in 2009
unsuccessfully realizing it wasn't the
right time I went and made two other
features and we did other stuff and then
after Nebraska circled back around to it
and even then it coalesced and fell
apart a couple times before finally
coming together when you think back to
the original idea that you had the
original spark of the story to the movie
end up reflecting that spark pretty
authentically even if you if it took
different paths as you were writing it
yeah yeah for sure and what was that
spark what was well initially uh well I
mean there was there was one spark which
was my brother was thinking about making
people tiny and talking to me about it
and he wasn't thinking about a movie he
just was what if he yeah making some
calculations and then I thought I don't
that could make an interesting movie and
and really what when when I say it it
the the most important thing for all of
us I think
as we were making this movie that has a
lot of visual effects in it and is sort
of on a different scale than other
movies majors we wanted to make sure
that it still felt like a movie about
people and a movie that Alexander made
and I remember watching the first cut
without the visual effects and
everything and saying looks like an
Alexander Payne movie and that made me
happy
how long do you remember that a first
meeting about this film and why this
part was important to you I do I do i
well when I went in and read for John he
told me that was very lovely what you
did and you know just sit tight because
you're not gonna hear anything for two
months and I heard two days later that
Alexander had seen seen my audition tape
so that was an incredibly exciting phone
call to get and then to get to meet this
man that I had admired for a very long
time I've seen all of Alexander's films
and I was a little bit of a goober I
didn't think that I made a really strong
impression on him I I thought well he
thinks I'm a good egg but I don't know I
might have talked myself out of the role
honestly though just not to bore you
with the anecdote you might not be
interested in but I was I was I liked
her audition tape so much that I told
John please arrange for me to have a
coffee when her with her because when
she came back for the callback I wanted
to I wanted to make I wanted to have her
succeed so I could get to know her a
little bit and then could give her some
direction market Alexander has a team
with whom he works very closely
Jim is a member of that music Ralph
can't costumes Wendy Chuck editor Kevin
10:00
Faden Papa Michel cinematographer core
group you're the interloper right how
did you have work your way into the
circle well you said when when I talked
to you about it earlier said a lot of
guys must have turned the job down
oh you kidding I have to say that the
opportunity to to produce an Alexander
Payne movie just too delicious and so
Alexander called me up and asked me if I
wanted to do it I probably took all of
seven seconds before I said yes but it
we've been working on something we've
known each other for a long time never
really done a film together and we've
been working on something a film that we
still hope to do at some point in
Spanish since we both speak Spanish and
it's based on a on a short story we both
like a lot and it was just going along
well and I think the the timing was was
perfect so Alexander asked me if I'd
come in this was about three years ago
so I really am a newcomer can I ask
about the day you shot the scene where
your character says that she wants to go
to Norway can you talk a little bit
about that day and about what that meant
to you as an action what that meant to
you to director well oddly it's those
big scenes that I actually don't really
try to overthink I of course I know that
it's important in the movie but
hopefully if I'm if I've done all of my
homework right it's not this thing that
I really have to muscle and everything
that I prepared for all of the other
scenes and all of the character work is
is going to give me that momentum to do
a big scene like that and that was
actually our first take and that's a big
one that in the film is the first I
could never do that with you know to
deliver an intimate performance and and
cry with those lights and the unblinking
Cyclops of the camera creeping steadily
close and having that concentration and
focus how the hell do you anyway I a
neat thing about being director is
watching these people do that watching
these great actors do that stuff it's
pretty unbelievable when you were
thinking about the production design
about what this leisure land is going to
look like I was thinking about
celebration the Disney city in Florida I
was thinking of the queen of Versailles
the document
about those houses with their reference
that you all talked about about what
this made-up world would look like and
where did you end up either creating it
or filming it yeah it's sort of a combo
pack among Orlando Palm Springs and Las
Vegas I didn't want it to have that kind
of precious precision that you maybe saw
in Edward Scissorhands or or The Truman
Show it still should feel real and lived
in and so forth and a lot of it is
designed I mean when they're in the the
viewing corridor early on and looking
through the big windows that's all
digital but based on months and months
of designed by urban planners we hired
like really what would this be and then
in terms of the houses there we found
locations you think Canadians are all
thrifty and modest and stuff they ain't
it's all a big front they have that some
of the most hideous opulent mansions and
McMansions you've ever seen in your life
up there this is near Toronto on
Southside outside of Toronto yeah so the
the house where they deliver Matt Damon
his big castle is is a location in in
Toronto they all were they all were I
want to ask you about this idea of this
city being walled off and then the
people who work in it who support it
being walled off certainly that's a
topical idea how early in the story was
there a wall or the separation between
the haves and have-nots well that is a
case of the world catching up with us
sadly yes we had yes we had written that
in fairly early on before there was any
before a wall was even a twinkle in our
president's eye but you know I would say
this kind of off topic but I was it's so
hard to comprehend people accepting this
absurd idea of building this wall around
our country but I guess so many
communities now are bill
has walled communities that it's become
a more an idea that's easier to
comprehend I want to come back to
casting about getting mad on and what
Matt meant to the film in terms of
getting a mate did that help and oh god
yeah so big bankable movie stars thank
god he exists
had he not existed I don't know whom I
would have cast no seriously and I
needed a wonderful actor who I also
believe can play in every man in his mid
40s
and who can also help me get a hefty
budget and there's really only Matt
Damon mr. Hanks could have done it but
he's a little older and Jen you know
half a generation older and and so not
quite right could have played it ten
years ago probably wouldn't shave his
head either
well that was movie man Tom my goodness
didn't see my barber then but Damon
Damon is the guy Damon's the guy
Alexander Jim Mara Kong thank you for
bringing us your movie